botar todos o trânsito aqui hoje é uma é
uma breve reflexão sobre sobre o lugar
da nossa vida é ele que é uma breve
reflexão porque como sabemos todos
a arte é uma área este sítio é um
matemático é muito complexa e portanto
nem eu seria a pessoa mais indicada para
falar disso nem o tempo que nós dispomos
aqui deveria tirar qualquer conclusão
portanto o que eu vou fazer a partir
desse princípio é que é vou contar muito
com a vossa colaboração portanto convoca
desde já é imaginar muito vamos pôr a
cabeça a funcionar e portanto esta
intervenção vai ter uma espécie de
substituto que é breve exercício de
certificação
esta palavra também foi apresentada a
primeira vez hoje já vai ter uma coisa
completamente nova e é ideia é antes de
mais um pássaro é é desenvolver o
exercício é que estamos aqui
já uma moção balizar aqui uma noção do
que vamos passar a entender por aqui
neste neste mês pelo período de doca e
portanto depois poderemos começar a
desenvolver se e portanto vamos partir
do princípio que a arte é tudo o que
está para além das nossas das nossas
cidades vitais nas partidas deste
conceito muito muito muito muito toscos
portanto falar em que está
são as nossas sociedades vitais como
dizia falem do que são as nossas nossas
capacidades tecnológicas portanto vamos
considerar que a arte é tudo que é
symbol enquanto do que a educativa de
algo é tudo que tem um sentido estético
e portanto há sim muito recentemente
será isso ser essa noção eu começamos a
é imaginar as coisas importantes
o primeiro desafio que eu fazia era
imaginar que
um dia de manhã em que nós levantamos
acordamos e damos conta que tudo o nosso
quarto estado em frente
portanto a nossa cama já não é nossa
cama que ela quer né
toda estilosa toda bonita que nós
tínhamos já não é nossa é uma coisa
muito elementar muito básica muito
utilitária nós candia era um companheiro
me disse uma coisa design brutal é uma
lâmpada com fillipi dourado começa a ser
um dia muito traumático e vamos andando
pela casa o tempo vai passando e nós
vamos começar a perceber que o fato toda
a casa se transformou e portanto houve
aqui um sinal no que é o tal de
certificação é que tudo que nós tenhamos
que dizia respeito a este este grande
grande e grande espaço grande território
que tenha a ver com a beleza e tem a ver
com com com isso cassel e daí ver com
tudo isso tenha sido possível as nossas
roupas passarão a ser isentas
desapareceram os padrões apareceram os
cosuel é e tudo que na casa dizia
respeito a gente tinha essa partida
enfim estava cansado mal é e nós vamos
tentando arranjar soluções para pelo
menos tentar perceber o que estava a
passar mas atribuindo começaria de
justificações eventualmente austeridade
no sangue jovem o que nesse dia por
acaso temos e vamos imaginar também
temos uma visita de boa viagem planeada
tínhamos umas ir a qualquer europa uma
cidade desportiva e se virmos a perícia
cidade bonita reconhecidamente bonita é
com com um enormíssimo wars e artístico
e portanto lá fomos nós chegamos atores
e quando damos conta por está exatamente
como estava a nossa casa portanto tudo
passou a ser cinzento extremamente
funcional sem nenhum tipo de beleza como
nós conhecíamos e como como toda a gente
sabe e portanto a cidade era uma cidade
edifícios cinzentos todos com as portas
iguais todos com generosos iguais todos
mesmo também todos completamente
diferenciados nas ruas
joão carlos o rei vai as coisas sem
curiosamente nenhuma sem nenhum tipo de
museu particular caixotes coisas com
rodas muito muito tributários mas só por
aí
depois claro quanto quanto aquelas
referências que se dá em todos sabemos
torre enfel 0 não estava lá
lugo 10 dias a partir do novo
nós pretendemos aproveitar a vida
política prometeu souza cardoso
vamos ver o que o qual é o dia que
deveria ser mais estranho
imagine agora se for possível como é que
seriam as pessoas na cidade dessas
comarcas sofriam com certeza todas
isentas
a roupa também como não via padrões
houve nenhum tipo de movimento estético
eram coisas todas as multifuncionais
todos muito iguais
tudo muito linear e portanto é era um
dia e era um mundo extremamente
extremamente estranho o comportamento
estranho viário e nós estamos a tentar
arranjar soluções para explicar isso
deixe desta desde breve exercício o que
é que tem que nós conseguimos reduzir
daqui é que pra nós estamos aqui a
tentar imaginar esse cenário a uma
enormíssima dificuldade em conseguir um
mundo assim nós estamos preparados para
conseguir um mundo onde não haja esse
tipo de ingredientes e nós não
conseguimos imaginar o mundo que seja
estritamente funcional estritamente um
mecânico o utilitário é desprovida de
qualquer sentido estético é desprovido
de qualquer sentido educativo e symbol e
nós não estamos preparados para suportar
a primeira edição nós conseguimos tirar
daqui é que nem mesmo ele ficou lá por
mais que meninas anfer tempo consigo
imaginar o mundo assim a segunda do sol
e tem a ver com as pessoas
quando tentamos imaginar
pessoas e quando tentamos perceber o que
é que vai na cabeça das pessoas com
certeza é fácil dizer que as pessoas
teriam seriam pessoas tristes combate
que as pessoas até 17 provavelmente só
os pães em uma série de enfermidades
porque só que não é não será fácil viver
no mundo onde um deste tipo de
ingrediente que são tipicamente humanos
são intrinsecamente nosso e não estão
presentes importante essa é seria uma
redução relativamente fácil de onde
seria muito fácil antiga
portanto o que é que nós decidir em
breve se o exercício e descomprometido
convém dizer é o que é que nós podemos
concluir que o facto de toda a nossa
vida a volta e tudo que nós temos e onde
estamos e os sons é é arte é uma
presença e intensa presença extremamente
válido extremamente importantes e iria
até que vital não damos conta disso na
maior parte dos casos praticados num não
damos conta de que o esforço que nós
temos é importante porque coloca uma
determinada coisa os padrões evoca
outras coisas são importantes e portanto
que tudo isto é que o público daí tem um
valor simbólico é e que nos nos leva a
um estado sublimação que sua ausência
não nos permite ao longo da nossa
história é a artista está presente
para ilustrar o nosso as nossas
sociedades das nossas conquistas das
nossas convicções vai continuar a estar
esperemos que saibamos dias é um é
grande questão que que expõe a dada
altura e que resulta do estudo esta
província é gravíssima reflexão é até
que ponto é que nós como agentes
passivos de agente transformador do
nosso do nosso mundo e do tempo em que
gastamos porque isso é muito importante
este período de prova em castanhas
até que ponto é que nós temos as
ferramentas
e cultivamos as ferramentas e
pertencentes às ferramentas poder
perceber isto perceber a importância que
ela tem na nossa vida
de que forma é que podemos projetar isso
no nosso dia a dia no nosso cotidiano
desenvolver criar proximidade com ela é
em vez de como acontece em mil e por
força de uma série de circunstâncias
andarmos muitas vezes é verdade dela e
temos uma uma relação com ela alguma
estranheza alguma alguma distância diria
até e incorrendo no risco de cheia
expressa damos um lado ao outro e
passarmos a ser isentas circunspectos e
e cada vez mais interessante é uma coisa
que eu espero que nós chance com certeza
nós sejamos nem nunca tenho certeza que
nos que nos leva a isso é importante
desafio final
o que eu gostava de lançar aqui uma
espécie de final
trabalho de casa era com base neste era
você imaginar em mais uma vez é mais um
caminho mais diferentes forças e
incentivo é imaginar aquilo que seria o
vosso que ele tinha um lado caso voz
quente em predileta higiene a vossa
salvar os cortes o city com vocês mais
gostam
imaginem que eu tem um quadro na parede
tem um sítio fantástico como a escultura
a uma música qualquer contato cara um
canto a um livre em cima da mesa e o que
estava próxima de nascem mais uma vez
como disse era concursado
obrigado